Mira yo creo que es importante reconocer
que los diálogos a nivel de la política
internacional ocurren en distintas
dimensiones y con distinto grado de
visibilidad en general nos tendemos a
concentrar en diálogos de mucha
rimbombancia como son los diálogos
presidenciales pero no hay que
desconocer que la historia política
indica de que detrás de esa visibilidad
se esconden a veces diálogos que no
Pasan a formar parte del conocimiento de
la opinión pública y en este escenario
de guerra en un escenario donde el
manejo la comunicación política y de la
narrativa es absolutamente clave
instancias como esta deben ser
calculadas por parte de quienes están en
juego particularmente Vladimir Putin que
ha insistido fundamentalmente en tres
cosas número uno que la guerra es una
guerra de carácter defensiva por parte
de Rusia y que responde a lo que ellos
consideran una agresión de lotan y
violaciones que Está realizando Ucrania
en el Oriente de dicho país número dos
de que hay un interés y redentista de
Rusia de recuperar territorios que
alguna vez fueron parte histórica o
cultural o culturalmente propio y número
tres que la guerra no va a terminar sin
antes la desmilitarización del país la
desnasificación del país la neutralidad
también de Ucrania y el reconocimiento
de alguna de las provincias ucranianas
donest
luansón como parte de la federación rusa
ahora uno toma esos tres elementos y
evidentemente uno se da cuenta que
parece razonable parece calculado y
parece racional el hecho que Putin al
menos postergue un diálogo con la
contraparte estadounidense no solamente
porque tienen objetivos diametralmente
distintos sino porque la señal de
aceptar un diálogo con biden en estos
momentos donde el ejército ruso se
encuentran retirada donde la opinión
pública
moscovita está relativamente fragmentada
y donde comienzan a aparecer críticas a
a Putin puede ser un riesgo innecesario
en en circunstancias que son bien
complejas para la rusa en el escenario
de guerra guido nueve meses pasaron ya
casi desde el inicio de la guerra desde
su perspectiva no Cómo ves la proyección
de un eventual e hipotético por supuesto
final del conflicto y qué podemos
esperar para el año que viene
lo veo bien difícil la verdad me parece
de que la experiencia de este año ha
indicado de que la puesta de capital
político es tan alto que pensar en una
salida negociada a estas alturas cuando
viene el invierno europeo es muy poco
probable mi estimación es que debiéramos
observar un desarrollo todavía
permanente de la guerra probablemente
por la totalidad del año 2023 quizá hay
alguna alternativa A mediados de año que
hoy día los analistas no están en
condiciones de observar pero si la
trayectoria se mantiene como se ha
mantenido uno debiera observar de que
Ucrania no va a detener sus esfuerzos
militares que vienen obviamente
acompañados de el apoyo en insumos por
parte de occidente sin antes recuperar
aquella zona que Rusia unilateralmente
anexó a partir de una plataforma de
referéndum que ha sido muy muy criticada
y cuando eso y si es que eso no ocurre
uno debiera entonces mantener unas
perspectivas pesimistas de de guerra
porque obviamente La pregunta es está
dispuesto a Ucrania a perder cuatro
provincias de su propio territorio con
tal de finalizar un conflicto de este
carácter Creo yo que la respuesta ahí es
no